[Music]
all right welcome everybody this is
Grandmaster Alexandra Lenderman with the
viewers Choice Edition so we're gonna
start with the game right here by fellow
named Aaron Welker you know he's playing
black in this game and he's the one who
sent the game he says he's been playing
for about two years started when he was
29 that's what my age is right now he's
only played a few years he have games
and my ratings told professional but
from what you will see he was actually a
pretty good player and concerning that
was a relatively short game 10 minute
game it was a pretty well quality game
pretty high quality game as we'll see so
let's start with this game it was a
CARICOM so white played a little bit of
a sideline with Bishop d3 I mean the
main line is Knight of three here that's
called a short variation after e3 Bishop
e2 that's considered the most common at
the top level also there is a very sharp
line h4 very ambitious one as well as
many other lines certainly you know very
possible but Bishop d3 is considered
relatively harmless because once black
is able to trade off this Bishop on f5
we know in general the lights per bishop
usually that means he solves a lot of
his opening problems so that's why this
move is considered a little bit
unambitious usually white tries to keep
pieces on the board with the space
advantage and try to play thanks to the
fact the block is a bit cramped like
it's not easy for black to find good
harmony for both his Knight and his
bishop you know usually you know black
has to be a bit creative how he
continues like for example blacks and
then zones I'm going for some stuff like
Knight c8 which you know it's fine of
course but it's a bit awkward or there's
stuff like Bishop g6 905 which then you
have to watch for g4 sometimes so all in
all you know there are some
inconveniences that's why it's more
common considered to play Knight f3 or
something but Bishop d3 is still a move
of course takes takes so now he's 6a 45
and now black is
more or less comfortable here okay so
all of this made a lot of sense all of
these moves are pretty logical here I
would say black had an improvement so I
would say in this position couldn't be
six was a bit better just to apply more
pressure here in the center and also at
the same time maybe prevent white from
comfortably developing his bishop on c1
so I thought that would have been
actually pretty good and I think black
is actually slightly better in this
position it's not so easy for white to
get his pieces developed c2 x d4 was
played which i think is a little bit
inaccurate it releases the tension
prematurely because white wasn't gonna
take on c5 probably and then it also
gives us not a nice developing square
sorry bad arrow white took with the
knight and now I think Bishop III should
have been played King h1
yeah and here I would say black has a
comfortable position here I thought
instead of the move Queen b8 night of
five was a worthy alternative just
immediately challenging the bishop and
then maybe taking back with the Queen
Queen b8 was played instead now that
gives white a chance to play Knight b3
which potentially allows him to control
the c5 square a little bit more Knight
a5 Bishop of to rook c8 and now I think
white should have played g4 and started
playing for initiative while these
pieces are a little bit off site on the
on the Queen side so I think g4 should
have been played in this position white
played Ruby 1 and now black played c5 it
was also pretty good to take first and
then play c5 c 5 was played Queen B 5 a
6 and here instead of a 6 C 4 was rather
interesting a 6 was played Queen e2
Queen a 7 and I did too and here I think
black made a positional mistake
black played d4 I don't like the smooth
because now this Bishop on b6 will be
very unhappy you see black is now
putting all his pawns on dark squares
and this Bishop is on a dark square that
means this bishop will potentially
almost always be restricted and now
after a simple move like 94 I think
white is again a little bit better
because now blacks counter plays just
kind of shut down sure black has this
pawn on d4 but it's not going anywhere
and now those bishop is kind of wasted
bad piece
so I think this was not the best plan I
think c4 was probably cold for a ruby
ate first or something like that but he
did this which allowed the tactic d3
it's a very nice tactic based on the
idea that if you take here I will take
this and black is winning so white had
to go here because of this then this is
captured so Queen d2 Roxy - this is
forced
and here especially given that it's a
blitz game we can't really criticize
rook takes B to a normal move you know
getting back to pawn still keeping the
rook active but technically speaking
even better was to play rock a c8
getting that last piece in the game and
White has no good way to vet to defend
the poor and black actually has some
attacking plants like for example if you
do something like this then maybe
already this and this stuff could be
very dangerous okay rook takes b2 takes
takes still white is better black is
better and these moves are all normal
and black here played Queen f1 here I
would have preferred King g7 the Queen
is good is already good as it is on c1
but it's good to go King g7 just to get
out of any possible annoying checks so I
think King g7 was a good move to play
Queen f1 Queen f3 Queen a 1 and here
Queen c4 was a little bit more accurate
because then the a6 sport porn is
protected and this is still hanging and
most likely this will win the porn
somehow instead Queen e1 was played and
now the game kind of was complicated
Queen a8 black is still not worse
because black has very good compensation
for the porn very very active pieces
well black is not better anymore because
white could still defend this and okay
black could get the pawn back but it's
not gonna be anything that's special and
indeed you know the game went
complicated I mean black was able to get
the porn back but there is no real
mating attack and in the meantime we
have to watch for this form and the rest
of this was time pressure play and even
in this position black is doing fine but
unfortunately okay it was a blitz game
probably no increment and it ended a bit
abruptly with this blunder but what can
we say the game was pretty good
no definitely Aaron showed a lot of very
good potential in this game the loss
doesn't really reflect how well he can
play definitely a lot of very good
moments just a couple of you know
improvements but considering it was a 10
minute game I would say this was a
pretty high quality game does anyone
have any questions on this game I would
still take block here because I think
that white has a slightly weakened King
and whenever it's a queen end game
that's a very important factor and the
pawn on d5 could become weak and it's
still gonna be hard to do anything
without porn so given that it's a queer
end game I would say I would take black
probably but it's probably around equal
but if it would be a rockin game and the
rope can go to let's say a 2y and then
of course I would take the passport and
then this is hard to do much with so it
depends on which pieces you know and you
know it's also depends on that it's not
just based on the bone structure all
right all right now we'll look at the
game from Henrik Bourbon Henrik
submitted the game he played this game
against Eric Claussen so Henrik was
white
and hunger care played d5 which is a
good move you can also just play Knight
f3 Knight c3 keeping the tension that's
what I would probably do but I don't see
anything wrong with d5 it's also viable
move gaining space Knight of 6 I think
it was more precise to start with the
move Bishop e7 with the idea that after
this you can play Bishop g5 trade off
these bishops because with this pawn
structure pawns on the dark squares at
some point that Bishop might become a
bad piece the bishop on e7 so that's why
it's a good idea to try to trade it off
or you can even consider this and this
okay well night of 693 it should be 7
okay here I think white made a
strategical mistake in this position
white has a very stable advantage a nice
space advantage so a move like Bishop e3
castles Bishop e2 would kind of secure
it then your goal is to maybe play
Knight of 392 castle and then just plan
the Queen side and white would be a
little bit better in this structure you
know because she has space advantage
black has a passive Bishop on e7 I mean
black is is very solid in the structure
but he's also passive so I mean next
move could be h3 stopping Knight g4 then
we can play Knight f3 then 92 castle and
I don't see what what is blacks plan
it's not so easy for black to play in
this position so I would say white is
better but instead of that white went
for more white one for more space but I
think this actually plays in blacks
hands because now if f4 move gives up
control over the e5 square potentially
so this I don't like as much and I think
black should have taken that takes that
castles then play rook e8 Bishop f8 put
pressure on e4 get control over a5 even
thinking about 95 I think suddenly here
all of blacks pieces make sense
and
more importantly now this Bishop on e7
has more room to play potentially from
of six because now there's no porn wall
so for example after this this this you
know you black and start thinking about
plan like this Bishop f6 95 and the
bishop will eventually feel itself at
home I mean maybe I'm not playing in a
perfect way but in general that's how
black wants to play this black played c6
which is also acceptable trying to also
challenge the space but I would prefer
would've preferred it takes a four-night
of three Queen c7 castles was also good
here Bishop d3 Knight of fate
so you see black is playing in the same
way as he would have if Y didn't play a
four but again when whenever opponent
does something that's a little bit out
of your system and this is more like a
thing for the black player you have to
also adjust to it and play different I
mean there's no reason to do this whole
night of 896 maneuver when the knight
already from d7 has a lot of impact on
the game through these squares so once
he gives you an opportunity with a four
there's no reason to do the same 9 if
896 plan it would make sense that the
porns was on a 2 and then there was no
other prospect for the night besides
that plan but now it doesn't make sense
to do that and here I think H to H
instead of h3 f5 was actually quite good
and restricting that night gaining space
to ways and this is usually decisive
whenever you can get the control of two
spaces white played h3 which is still
okay and from here on black seemed to
really lose the threat I mean at some
point knight c6 should be played somehow
just completing your development but h6
is too slow and then it's specially g5
you can't play just like that when
you're underdeveloped you know white is
fully developed castled and black is not
fully developed and yet is
for the spawn play it doesn't work and
naturally all the tactics now work in
White's favor and from this point on
white played the game exceptionally well
brilliantly 965 starting with a simple
tactic based on the idea of this this so
black has to go here night 6 of 7 night
6 of 1 queen h5 another very nice move
Queen decks of 1 scores of course also
pretty good probably but queen h5 is
very strong threatening this and also
threatening this rook 93 and now another
race strong move for white 96
double-check exclam double-check the
King has to move only place to go to d7
otherwise it's made right away Queenie a
check takes and now a very nice quiet
move Bishop g4 exclam threatening made
two ways c5 e 5 it's almost like you
know a romantic game you know almost
like you know games that we'll be seeing
in an hour
Queen d7 c5 check King c7 Bishop e5 King
walk Bishop d6 only move and now it's
you know a mop-up and here after another
fork which recouped recouped some more
material and also potentially a maid
mating attack coming
black threw in the towel so very nice
attacking game by white seizing his
opportunities once black violated some
principles and what once black played
some mistakes but that doesn't mean that
let's say the strategy in the beginning
was correct
therefore plan was still a mistake in my
opinion and I certainly of black reacts
to it in the best possible way black
would be the one having fun being a
little bit better instead of white
but once white took advantage of his
chances he wants white goddess chances
he took advantage of them very well
all right any questions yes she
um yeah I mean I think I think you
should try that I think from what I've
run without enough from what I remember
white is still better but I mean you can
probably just take the rook but okay you
can also play these six probably these
six would have been the idea if you saw
that move now if you only take the rook
then actually you're right then it's not
so clear King g7 it's like very sharp
maybe black is better but you can play
these six that's the point
Bishop takes takes here here and then e
5r c five and of course if King g8 Queen
e8 mates
so yeah there is still you know a
winning attack for for white winning the
game but yes I agree that would have
been more resilient well I think when
you play Knight g3 he thought he got him
because the Queen has nowhere to go
and then you're gonna save the rook and
then black will be fine but he missed
probably the ninety six with a very
powerful attack so that was that's why
whenever you play chess you gotta
consider all of your opponent's options
all of their active especially active
moves checks captures threats including
double checks ninety six especially
double checks double checks most
importantly because they're like closest
to mate possible in some ways yeah any
other questions
all right next game then all right this
is a game from Allah Reza hi my name is
Ala Reza I'm from Iran I watched her
al-sham Aradia bodies last video on st.
Louis you change you to Tube channel and
I want to show you this game that I
managed to be the 2200 rated player and
leaches 10-0 my rating is 1960 yes well
this game was indeed a very well played
game by the way
does anyone know here which other
Alireza is like a very strong player in
Iran like what's his last name
Perugia yes so this guy's lucky he
shares the same first name with a very
very strong and famous young Grandmaster
only 16 years old and already almost
2700 fidei he crushed me actually in an
in in one game recently in a World Team
Championship which stay tuned that that
game might be in in the Tuesday lecture
my greatest losses but for now we're
gonna see this a Loretta's game which
was also a very nice game so C 4 C 5 G
ala Reza is white yes not Perugia but
the other other sg3 Knight of 6
Bishop g2 d5 takes takes Knight c3 99-93
6 Queen b3 interesting move I I
personally would have probably just
developed but Queen b3 is certainly also
quite interesting actually very
interesting move trying to disturb the
harmony for black a little bit trying to
make that knight move a little bit night
before a three-night c6 ok at least now
it's a little bit clumsy for the other
night Knight of 3 all of these moves are
pretty natural but black here is going
for a very slow plan this whole plan of
F King h8 and f6 is very dubious to say
the least because it violates a lot of
opening principles
I mean blacks pieces are not really
developed and and yet you're spending
two moves just to try to get e5 in he
had to have done something else tried to
get that 97 maybe something like 97
Knight of six somehow get his pieces
coordinated right away but yeah this was
too slow and now how would you try to
take advantage of blacks poor
coordination here as white like what
would you try to play in this position
that's what was played in the game but
at least then after he 5 Bishop III
black could play b6 and he still has
some things under control and actually
it's maybe not so bad for black suddenly
so let's try to improve on Alireza play
in this particular moment Ashish efore
will that that move is strategically I
think very risky because we're weakening
the square somehow i mean maybe i won't
i won't go if if i've even right away
but I can play b5 but should be 7 I mean
in the long run that such a move is very
risky I will say yeah Adi
night a for very good well I mean either
night a for or there should be three
first and then if be six you know some I
think some 94-94 but yeah night a for is
also pretty good yeah because you need
to control this square that's the idea
instead you know 94 was played which is
more natural but now II five Bishop III
at least at least here be six would have
kept blacks position intact but 94 was
played and that move is a mistake
because it you're basically trading off
you're only developed piece and now this
Bishop on g2 opens up and after Bishop
d2 it's still very hard for block to
really get pieces out for example knight
c6 is met by Knight 895 still kind of
trouble for black so Rukh a7 was played
95 be 696 takes takes Queen d6 Queen b3
b5 this should be for Queen d7 and from
here on I really like Alison play
getting full control over that C file
now first with the subtle move Bishop c5
but after this not taking but going this
should be six also very very interesting
takes takes rook c8 takes takes okay
what should why do now in this position
yeah
yeah very good queen of seven was very
powerful
instead age four was played 97
Queeny six night takes and here Queen
Dex e 7 was probably stronger keeping
block with the night and threatening
this white took here and here black had
a chance to get back in again with the
move Bishop c5 kind of dislodging this
Queen on b6 but black played here
Bishop f3 g6 and now white got control
over the game and once before it's
played then now you went here anyone
there and from here on yeah maybe white
can play a little better like mystery
for but ultimately this was probably
time pressure but from this point on I
would say white won the rest of the game
without too much difficulties so it was
a very nice game exploiting the fact of
the black played too slowly in the
opening and really seizing the
initiative sure it wasn't 100% perfect
that allowed like some b6 defenses but
all in all still a very nice instructive
game by Alireza winning against the
higher rated player who took too much
liberties in the opening yeah
the Queen couldn't quite come down I was
Western yeah yeah well then then Bishop
f1 and then those made problems Queen of
fate um yeah I would say here White has
several choices you can first of all go
Queen e6 and then black really can't
move anything right you know you're
gonna go this should be seven Bishop
Bishop here I mean you're gonna win the
pawns and black in the meantime is a bit
struggling I mean not to mention endgame
yeah might also be a big problem
although although this yeah this okay
probably is also much better for for
white but maybe it's not a Z but yeah it
should also be winning
so trading Queens also doesn't really
help yeah so Queen f7 was really a
powerful move
I mean h4 gave some defensive chances I
mean so again it's a 10-minute game so
the execution was not a hundred percent
perfect but it was still a very
high-quality game alright any questions
on this game
alright so let's let's move on to the
next one
all right let's go over now Steve
Martin's game against the suit harka
Palama Cumbre paalam McCumber ah okay
f4 f5 alright so this is a this is a
rule opus for Knights you know
definitely very playable line 94 yeah 94
is considered like the main line theory
in this position Bishop c4 Bishop c5 and
here you could take on e5 but it leads
to very sharp complications which I
think current theory claims that it's a
draw as far as I know it's like a very
sharp line I think I'm just 24 young
Gustafson covers that stuff very well
for black so d3 is kind of a safe way to
play to avoid Mesa complications
although of course black has no problems
in this line d69 a4 and here I think b5
as as far as I remember is supposed to
be the main move to deal with this with
this
there should be six was played instead
night 64 which takes d4 c3 this should
be six now white at least has a little
bit of a pool maybe Queenie 7 all of
this makes a lot of sense why is
challenging the center d5 square castles
Bishop e6 okay here in this position it
was a little bit stronger to take on e6
first and then just go a3 and just the
you know not taking a right away and
keeping this one flexible and just
having a little bit of a pressure a
little bit of a pull here in this
position alright so instead of that f e5
was played d5 Bishop takes Queen takes
now a three but now okay white release
the tension without you no real reason
again you know my recommendation to you
guys' don't release the tension unless
you're pretty sure it's gonna be in your
favor because it's one of these typical
cases where black isn't really
threatening to take this and in the
meantime your porn porn has flexibility
to go to a point f5 and also you can
always choose the right time to take but
there's no point of releasing the
tension let's say and now black has an
open D file and voila you have pressure
on the g3 yes
um I mean I for just potentially have to
calculate some b5 I think it just a for
is a little bit more vulnerable I mean
maybe a four has some points I mean an
endgame you know you're fixing the b6
point only if you're thinking about that
but I think for now a3 is safer because
if you go away for I might even be able
to play b5 and now you're kind of a
little bit tied down to that porn yeah
but but then yeah that then still that
porn is kind of okay again kiken Castle
I mean you can go before but I mean my
formation is very solid also so I'm not
sure if this whole thing does give you
that much I think the point would be if
you can play Bishop III
before Queen c2 and keep your pawn here
and fix the sport you know on a dark
square only then it would make a little
bit of sense but if you're if you can
just go b5 and then I think a4 doesn't
have many big points maybe it's not a
mistake but I just think you're just
it's more work more calculation work for
you and not much upset upside right it's
important to play practical like what
are you gonna gain even if a 4 turns out
to be okay what are you gonna gain from
it nothing much but you might lose from
it if it turns out it's like a little
bit vulnerable right so it's like one of
these moves you can only regret but
there's like very little gain from it so
that's why it's more practical to play
three castles Bishop g5 97 good plan you
know nights coming here Queen of three
of six Bishop H 495 roopd one Ruby eight
rook e1
yeah and already here I think blacks
comfortable so black can play move like
Knight b3 and start doubling and it's
not easy for white to really find a
useful plan here the t3 Square is pretty
weak so the whole opening up of the D
file was a mistake Queen b3 Rosie -
Rosie what d6 the one
and here instead of Queen b5 Queen a4
was apparent a little bit more accurate
but because maybe then Knight b3 is a
threat and also it's harder to get the
foreign maybe ok Queen B 5 t 4e d CD 93
and now a whole big tactical
complication start so now my question to
you guys is this evaluate this move
Knight 64 is this a good movers is a bad
move and why
yeah
why
yeah
the chef to Luke takes yeah that's what
happened in the game but but rook takes
mm-hmm yeah that's what happened in the
game
well Queen said oh yeah yeah well I
don't think it's hook but I mean that's
that's what happened yeah so so in the
game he played a queen bee three but
that's still losing but white had a very
nice idea before a nice intermediate
move that's what it's very important to
always consider intermediate moves
especially once you see that maybe
Bishop have to move might lose or you
know doesn't really accomplish what you
want because in the end of all this
you're losing material here you're not
able to get what you want so it's
important to calculate lines till the
end and also from the black standpoint
of view yeah before you play a move like
Knight takes d4 you got to make sure you
Cal good till then and consider all
possible forcing moves from your
opponent including Queen b3 including
before like everything because if
somehow something doesn't work out you
might just lose my just losing a piece
so you know this is a while one of these
moves it's it's definitely worth playing
if it will work because the winds are
poor right so there is something to gain
from a move like that so that's why it
has a lot of practicality but at the
same time you have to be very careful
always and Cal Goodsell dent because
such a move is very responsible if it
doesn't work you just down a piece and
in this position before was a brilliant
opportunity that was missed this would
probably have won the game for white I
mean certainly it's still a game even
after this I mean you can give up you're
going to be down a piece basically you
can still no sir actually this would
lose sorry this should be one of course
so it would still be somewhat about the
game but it of course is losing for
black
but this was played and then after that
the rest of the game was a mop-up all
right guys any questions on this game
since earlier when you had the tension
with f4 before yeah
yeah well he took any five right so I
was recommending this in the night here
are five oh okay I'll go Queenie seven
probably yeah I think that's why I think
a three is a useful waiting move you
know just play a flexible move and see
what he does because in in some cases
you have this option open and this
option open just see what he does that's
what I'm saying that's why yeah I think
I think there's no reason to release the
tension right I don't I don't think you
need to force it right away because he
if he takes this you're not supposed to
be afraid of that then that just opens
up the file for you and in the meantime
he doesn't really do much for himself so
you're not really afraid of e takes off
or unless you're really afraid of each
sex of four there's no reason to you
know declare the tension so quickly
declare your intention be a little bit
more flexible in that regards no as you
said you he doesn't even have to Castle
right away right and plus if you do it
too quickly you know there are some
ideas like t5 for example challenging
the center you're giving some
opportunities so it's just you know play
a three and see what he does castles I
would probably play Queen f3 and then I
would you know I would see let him play
a move Knight for example if he goes
here maybe I would take this and then
try this painting the night somehow I
mean now I would be thinking about that
but let's see what he does first and
then we'll decide all right so let's
look at another game from Z yeah sir hi
this is Z yeah sir from Morocco I really
want you to analyze this game because it
has some interesting concepts to teach
to your pupils especially an endgame
it's a 10-minute game was full of
blunders I myself missed a lot of
winning moves but I managed to win at
the end with opponents advantage I was
shocked because I thought I was
completely winning yes let's this was
definitely had a lot of contents so
let's take a look at this game we're
gonna kind of skip through the opening
it was more interesting later in the
game yeah here I think it's more common
just to play Bhishma for c3 Queen c2
like more solid but okay white played a
more ambitious setup with c4 normally if
you go for c4 it would have been making
me more sense to play right away maybe
but okay Bishop d3 this is all fine
relatively speaking and here it was more
accurate to take on g5 because when you
go h3 he could potentially win the porn
even though there will be compensation
but I still think black is fine
Bishop h5 was played and here an idea of
note so everybody in case you're playing
these French structures sometimes White
has a movie g4 here
and this move is playable because this
isn't really that scary here I mean
there's really no attack
whereas Bishop g6 you can take you know
and then take some Queenie to let's see
and or or even Queen b3 and it actually
white gets a lot of play in all of these
positions so this is always something to
keep in mind you know this g4 is very
often an idea in these exchange French
structures it's something that's a
little bit underestimated but the engine
really likes that idea I mean of course
you have to time it correctly but you
know this could be a useful concept
alright Bishop f4 was played now I think
black should simply go 97 complete its
development instead she played bishop g6
for some reason releasing the pin now
white played 95 which is a good move
exchanging that bishop
and here I think white should take that
and if takes take again using the fact
that this is impossible
and if CD you can play Queen b3 and
start piling up pressure at least to
think is interesting maybe actually
start with rook c1 because that way
there is still no rook c8 and if Queen
d7 rooks g7 at least I think White has
pressure definite pressure so okay in
the game Queen of three was played takes
takes but should be six Queen of three
Queen c7 and now I like this move right
here d5 you know getting rid of ice Lani
and opening up the game some more for
your pieces take stakes and I like this
Bishop takes you know keeping that night
because that night actually has a big
impact on the attack so I think white
played very interesting
and here black made a mistake I think
instead of b6 rook c8 was better and now
white has a very nice initiative 97
and a very interesting move here Queen B
3 a very nice tactic based on the idea
that this is impossible
so Queen a1 was played King H 2:25 and
this is where the mistakes start so
first of all in this position very easy
winners are 4 so I think one of the
reasons why a 4 wasn't played is because
G 3 it's like first move that comes to
mind with maybe G 3 safeguarding the
King looks safe looks comfortable but
that's why when we see a good move we
don't play it right away we should look
for a better one a very good rule
because I think certainly if white would
have been looking for a 4/4 a better
move f4 would have been very easy to
find and in the game is just completely
over my group takes g7 rope takes off 8
and so on so g3 takes takes and now okay
rook takes a 7 is also probably winning
but Luca 4 was played they trying to go
for more but unfortunately those runs
and so g5 and here actually now white
stroke becomes a little bit out of place
and this actually is kind of fine for
black after move like Queen c5 but
instead black played g6 h4 and yeah here
there must have been time pressure
because here there was a mate missed so
this was played instead once again it
might be a consequence of seeing a good
move not looking for a better one
and in this position I would like you to
evaluate the move Queen III is the move
good or bad and why
why
yeah because the king is just not gonna
be in the square and the key is a 4
that's the key knob takes you know and
then white is winning but a 4 and the
king is not in a square that reminds me
of an interesting episode I remember
when I was a kid and you know I had a
friend who was around 1500 and then
there was a adult player who was around
1500 and I think he was up 2 points in
the in some Queen end game but then he's
thought okay
since there's since it's an end game up
2 points
you know automatically let's trade into
a porn end game that means it's winning
and then it turns out there was a
mistake because there's a past pone
another side of the board and then yeah
that like just like here and then my
friend asked him you know after he beat
him why did you do this move you you
know allowing me to trade Queens and get
into winning point and gaming he said oh
I wasn't even looking at the other part
of the board so that's why in chess it's
very important you know general common
rule for all of you like a nice reminder
you gotta always pay attention to the
whole board very important not just like
most of the board but the whole board
alright that's very very important and
look at all the for the possibilities
for opponent but interestingly enough in
this position I think apparently black
resigned or something the game ended up
with white winning so it was one of
these were black believed probably or
maybe it was some kind of a time
pressure may be lost on time or
something but anyway I think this was
possibly lost some time well anyway it
was it was something that you know was
an interesting episode which something
you go guys can all learn from alright
we have two more games so this guy says
I like your videos that's why I would
like you to burn my game the nether the
Netherlands is where I'm from and I'm
playing black the Sicilian defense
alrighty here we are
Sicilian defense okay so yeah white
played in a very subtle way I would
actually recommend here two systems one
system is to play five not letting white
ever again t foreign and then just
playing g6 Bishop g7 oh but if I but if
that thing is if you want to play 45 I
would played here then I will go here
then on goat-cheese six Bishop g7 ninety
seven castles and then I would play for
a five so the game can continue
something like this and I think the fact
of matter is black isn't better
positioned to attack because he has you
know he doesn't have to block that core
so I think from that standpoint of view
black has a practical advantage so
whenever you see c-4 in this kind of
position if five is a pretty logical way
because the way black played actually
white was able to get a favorable
position Marazzi bind now white can
actually play d4 and I think if white
plays d4 why premature gets everything
he gets c4 and he gets the foreign and
why just gets a nice comfortable space
advantage a good structure for white I
mean those could end up becoming a like
a Marazzi bind which i think is a little
bit better for white I think instead of
knight c6 here consistent would be
Bishop c4 you know now that you know
white has weakened all these dark
squares in particular d4 it makes sense
to really fight for it and therefore
exchange this problematic bishop on c8
for this Knight enough to me and then if
white goes here then at least you're
going to take that you're gonna go there
you're gonna go g6 Bishop g7 you know
then 97-95
and fight for all these dark squares
control so I think trading of this
Bishop for Knight is a typical idea in
the Sicilian to fight for all the dark
squares especially once once white plays
d4 it's a very important idea when white
plays he forced to get control over
these dark squares knight c6 was played
and now white made a blunder white
played 95 which black does not take
advantage blackberry 6 may
so quickly but in fact you can we just
win the porn in this position of course
why should play t4 here and here I would
play a very plan g6 followed by Bishop
g7 or maybe even a very ambitious move
g5 trying to really fight for all the
dark squares like I've mentioned before
with the movie g5 which is also a very
typical idea and some of these positions
like that even a very aggressive ultra
aggressive g5 because white can't
challenge the center very easily so
black in the meantime can seize
initiative on the other side plus there
is a developing move it the purpose is
also to develop the bishop so g5 is
pretty good here there should be seven
castles castles yeah and here instead of
castles black played 94 which I dislike
because it moves the same beast twice
which i think is definitely no point of
doing that Bishop e2 takes takes and now
we're having a long manoeuvring game
here
and who can tell us you know what should
black do in this position yeah that
one's pretty easy so if someone else to
find it who has maybe participated as
much today
black to play and find the best move
do you see it
now
rook takes b1 very good yeah
just wins the piece because Queen takes
takes and if this takes yeah this was
missed in the game by both sides Queen
b6 and then you know there are some
complications
and here black is white as actually
still better after move like lor okay
seven attacking the bishop which defends
the rook this could have kind of created
problems for for black this move was
missed
mister g4 was played instead takes now
he took the rook but the problem is now
black has too many attackers on the
other side the bishop is now not
defending and here black finished off
the game too as credit and very nice
style Bishop xh3 exclamation point so
the ideas of this we're going there and
I still think this is just I still think
it's not more than the draw and I can
double-check yeah it's it's still a draw
but for some reason why I did not take
it was afraid and played of three but I
didn't the ended up being even worse and
now black recouped the game in a very
nice way Queen takes g2 checkmate
so black did get a chance to finish this
game off in a nice way but you know for
this player we have to say yeah just you
know we need to work more on under
tactics I guess and then everything else
will get better from there on but yeah
the game was definitely very interesting
alright thanks for the game and then we
have one more game left and that is mark
Dakar against Lawrence who Lawrence who
is black as employee here okay so e4 e5
Knight f3 knight c6 and the player who
submitted is white and white here played
c4 which is a little bit unusual I mean
the most common moves are either t4 the
scotch or the rule opus or Bishop c4
Italian or even the Vienna some kind of
four knights or three nights but c4 is a
little bit have to say uncommon and
probably not so good in this position
and now black could okay just play
Bishop c5 normal development
well black really went for the
aggressive trying to
take the bull by its horn you don't
really take advantage of whites
misplaced pieces by play like a Kings
gambit reversed almost takes Bishop c5
g3 d6 and now it is like a Kings gambit
reversed G for a white holdouts the porn
now here black should probably go h5
right away after which I think black is
just better because you can't really
hold on to your structure but black
played Knight of 6 and after h3h 5 that
gives white a chance to go to g5 Bishop
takes takes takes and now it's like a
reversed Kings gambit with a knight sack
93 Bishop before and now white and this
position should go Bishop g2 and try to
Castle quickly as quickly as possible
now that he's up a piece he should
really get his king and safety that
should be the priority instead Bishop d2
was played that's I think a mistake
because after castles long now he ended
up going Bishop g5 which is still
winning but he could have gotten that
upper temple obviously so and again the
material is not the most important the
most important is once drop a piece you
have to safeguard your King and get your
you know and get yourself consolidated
so Queen g6 alright but she takes the
eight rook takes the eight all right
what do you guys think white should play
in this position
mm-hm so what do you think is best
okay what do you think Hadi
what about when you're up material
trade-off some piece of snide h4 I mean
get rid of the bishop the bishop is a
good attacking piece your upper rook
it's a trade off some pieces a simple
strategy right there should be two
castles and just you know whenever we're
up we have to simplify right that's
ultimately the goal of the game simplify
and we're up a rook you know the end
game will always be very easily winning
so we have to just make sure we take
away get rid of the extra garbage some
people like to say in the position you
know because Queen e2 is probably okay
but for example Queen e2 i sir you said
Queen d2 Queen d2 for example now you
have to think about this move right what
are you gonna do after 94 let's say
already a little bit uncomfortable yeah
but there should be two okay now you
have to calculate Queen g2 I mean what's
happening here I don't know it's a bit
messy maybe it's actually not good for
you I mean maybe there's some defense
but I don't know I don't see it right
away also you can have to calculate this
I mean just giving up a pawn and still
there's some initiative so again simple
simple chess and this doesn't really
lose you any temples because you're
trading off his piece right you're
attacking the Queen so it's not like
you're just aimlessly attacking your
trading and often now you complete your
development Bishop g2 Castle and game is
finished more or less and stead route g1
was played queenie 695 well this okay i
guess it's not technically still a
mistake but this is already a step in
the wrong direction and now for some
reason yeah why did not take this pawn
on d5 which should have been taken right
played back and now black is getting
initiative
and now here blacks place starts taking
full gear
and now this is being threatened and now
okay why it should still be your kind of
okay after Bush takes t3 you know get
rid of this very very nasty porn in your
territory and which controls a lot of
key squares like it frees up that King
to see to potentially give back some
material just to safeguard yourself and
I would say white is still doing okay
here but yeah this was played and after
this
now the porn is a very important
attacker as well and from here on
Lawrence who played very nicely Misha
takes b3 queen of three he made a knight
and very nice because of course if he
makes a queen there's Queen takes of two
and could still be that black is worse I
mean losing I don't know or maybe rook
the two wins but does it King I won I
don't know it's still a bit messy
I guess so night was very good decision
simplest and now black is the one up
material so white tries to get something
back but now a nice move rook t3 put
them to that attacking that Bishop and
then preparing our a4 and like is
winning here
and here white resigned so a little bit
of complex game but even in a complex
game there's certain is still simple
stuff to to learn sometimes you have to
just even if it's complicated
stick to the basic principles you know
just when you're up material simplify it
take care of the initiative end you know
simplify the game all right any
questions on this game
alright guys I guess we'll have a small
break and then we can start a romantic
lecture
you
[Music]